ايه ده في هذا المجلس ومن امام الجمل وعلى
يميني وعلى يساري الصقور نحن معكم في هذا
المجلس في العلا ومعانا موهبه طفل موهوب
عبد الله عبد الله الخم عليه هو شاعر يلقب
بابن العلا اهلا وسهلا فيك يا عبد الله شو
اخبارك طيب عساك طيب يا عبد الله عبد الله
طبعا شارك بالمسابقه اكتشاف المواهب على
ام بي سي دورتها الاولى في العلا واخذ
جائزه افضل اصغر متسابق وتفوق طبعا في
الالقاء واليوم عبدالله حيتحفنا في
الالقاء بدنا نسمع منك يا عبد الله هيك
قصيده عن العلا
عندي قصيده بالعلب من العلا دار الثقافه
والجمال ترى الحضاره من عاشور الاولين في
هالنخلفيات سالفيه الرمال فله يا اهل اللي
تسروا السامري فيها سحاب تعالوا قاروس
الجبال كانك تحسن بينهم شوق وحنين زيدان
مع الاحيان اثارهم لا يا زاد باقي ولا مره
ثلاثه من سنين و نجيتها وتستقبلك صف رد لا
والله حي وقرطه الحين
في ظل سلمان الحزم وافقصان
بعد الله الوالي عليها الاتكال المملكه
والمسلمين وهذه يا ابو سلمان زيزو ومرجان
قبله على كفه وقبله بالجبيل يا رقابنا يوم
الثريا فوق صرنا مع نجوم السماء
وطموحه ابعد من الحدود الفرقدين
صح لسانك يا عبد الله عبد الله تسمعنا
كمان قصيده بنخطب معك البرنامج يلا يا عبد
الله
في وقفتك عز من وين ما وجهت جبت الغنايم
ما كانك الا حر من ماين كرافت حرا على راس
الطويلات حايم عرس العدو انفعل يمناك تهتز
وانا ساعدني في محبتك هاي ومن حقنا نفخر
من مثلك ونعتز
ما شاء الله يا عبد الله عبد الله الكل
مستمتع وبعدين عم بيقولوا لي كمان وحده
هيك حابين نسمع منك عندك كمان واحده سريعه
برسل سلامي الولي عهد المملكه ما اعدمناه
اكبر طموحاتي وغايز مرامي تكبير راسك ثم
كتفه ويملكه
ودعواتك يا عبد الله صح لسانك انت فعلا
يعني ختمنا معك ختام جميل في صباح العربيه
نورتنا اليوم يا عبد الله وان شاء الله
بالتوفيق واكثر واكثر كمان شكرا يا عبد
الله
اذا مشاهدي صباح العربيه وسهام اعود اليك
لكي نختم سويا يعني كنا معكم طوال ثلاثه
ايام انتقلنا في اكثر من منطقه في العلا
بدانا من امام صخره الفيل حد معالم العلا
والعجائب الجيولوجيه فيها بفعل الطبيعه
وايضا كنا في ثاني يوم في البلده القديمه
التي ايضا
بتصنيف من واحده من اجمل القرى السياحيه
لعام 20 22 واليوم من امام احد المزارع
بمجلس جلسه عربيه بدويه اص لنعيش كيف كان
يعيش اهل العلا قديما على طريق ممر البخور
وقوافل الحجيج هنا في هذه المنطقه شكرا لك
يا نادين شكرا يا عبد الله منور